i've just written down the equation
believe it or not we can get pretty much
everything we need just off of this what
are the first things
that are asked of us it says write down
its center amplitude
and extremes of displacement that's a
bit of a weird phrase but we can get to
you might be able to infer what that's
asking for just by the language
let's start off with the center i
mentioned it right here
right if you start off with just your
vanilla old sine function
it's going up and down and the middle of
it is just
x equals zero right so when we introduce
this kind of vertical shift
whether it's up or down you just change
where that middle is so
which part of our equation is that
that's the three right on the end there
so i'm just going to say center of
motion
and then i'm going to say because i've
got lots of equations that are going to
be flying around for
displacement and velocity acceleration
i'm not just going to say it's 3
i'm going to say it's x equals 3 because
that's what displacement is it's x
choose the right perimeter you're going
to have a lot flying around
okay next thing amplitude you don't even
need to know that this is simple
harmonic motion
to look at this function and tell me
which number which value is going to
give you the amplitude here it's
2. right this is the part that tells you
how far up and down you can go so i'm
going to say
my amplitude and customarily we use
a because we're boring about that is
equal to two
now the extremes of displacement what
does that mean well extremes are like
what are the furthest places you can go
what's the most extreme
value so in this case um sometimes we'll
call them
extremities and i like to use that
because it's just
lazier it's only one word i'm going to
be from the middle and then you can see
how far
up and how far down you can go right
so here's my middle right here what's
the lowest you can go from x equals
three
you can go two units down to one and
then what's the highest you can go from
three
up to five so i can say my extremities
are x
equals one and x equals
five that's it i just read them off it's
my a
plus or minus sorry it's my x plus or
minus
a again
ah okay good question are my extremities
x equals one or x equals five i'm
actually describing something
which is plural so that's why i think
it's totally legit to say
and it's both of them you have to have
two extremes
um however i mean if you put a comma in
here i don't think anyone would be upset
with you okay hi that was part is that
all i was asking
for yep papi determine the period
initial phase and location
at time zero our initial
period or sorry our initial location our
period and our phase okay
how do we work out period of a
trigonometric
function if for example you started back
at let's just look at
like the most vanilla of all
trigonometric functions
its period in this case would be two pi
right when you add in this n i always
think to myself
oh if i had sine two t i've got two
copies of that within
two pi if i had sine three t i'd have
three copies within
two pi so what i'm doing really is i am
i'm dividing by whatever that
coefficient is okay so in this case i'm
going to say
my period is going to be 2 pi divided by
whatever my coefficient of excuse me
t is which in this case is pi on 2.
so just being careful for my fractions
on fractions there you can see why i
introduce brackets
pi's are going to cancel you get left
with
2 divided by a half which is four now
i'm just having a look
and noticing whether there are any units
for me and i don't think there
are but it's customary when you don't
get provided ones i'm pretty sure you
generally go with centimeters
and seconds so with this i could just
say four seconds but
i'm going to be even more um i'm going
to be even more vague and i'm just going
to say
time units because they didn't say
anything so i'm just going to go with
whatever
that's completely non-descript there's
the period
what's the next thing they asked for
initial
phase now coming back to here right you
saw me do this right
i introduced this extra angle in here to
say
i don't have to start at the origin i
can start anywhere right so just like we
did with amplitude
and very similar to and the center of
motion as well i can just read this off
what's the value in this particular one
pi on six that's it
okay last piece i think we've got all of
the bits now
to be able to say when time equals zero
initially time equals zero
implies x equals what are you gonna get
two sine this is zero so it's really
sine of pi on six
what's pi on six sine of pi and six
again
that's a half right that's a half plus
three
so i'm really getting two times a half
plus three
that looks like four to me okay with
that
and again uh i haven't provided units
here it's customarily
seconds but sorry centimeters but i'm
just going to go with units there just
to be ultra safe
all right last bit what's it asking
determine when the particle is next
at that spot right there how soon
does it take or how much time does it
take to get back to that spot
now have a think about this for a second
i could go straight to some equations
and that kind of thing and work out
what's going on
i know i'm going to be back there in
four time units
four seconds perhaps because that's the
entire period but can i get back there
sooner what do you think yeah
okay good good so in terms of the
symmetry of the sine function just have
a look here right
we already decided okay we're going
between one and five so picture
one being the bottom of that wave and
five being the top
and we're asking well how soon will we
get back to this position
four okay now we could go through one
entire
period of motion and of course you'd
return back because that's what a period
of motion is
but you can see if i just pause it
somewhere like that
right i'm going to go a little further
there we go just have a look at my
horizontal line right there okay
do you see there's another point of
intersection which happens much sooner
than in fact that was not the best
example i think i could
there we'll do it there you go so if you
imagine the first time
as the first intersection of that
horizontal line with
the sine wave okay and then there's
another one just
on the other side of the crest i don't
have to go all the way to the next
period to get one okay
so we need to find out what that is we
want to solve
for x equals this we already know one of
the answers will be this we also know
one of the answers will be this
can you find me one that is sooner or
between
these two can i let you have a play with
that it's just solving a trigonometric
equation
see if you can get a reasonable answer
for me off you go
i'm just mindful of time i was
originally going to do another example
for you but that's a bad idea so i'm
just going to show you
where this particular question ends did
you get
your four on three that's what i got
okay um do you have to set it out like
this no
but i like charm i was doing this
without a calculator and i wanted to
make sure i got all my
right values so i was just doing exact
values in my head
uh you can see me doing let's get the
right spot here
you can see me getting to a half and
then recognizing oh i know there's a
bunch
of values for pi on two t plus pi on six
that sine of that will give you a half
pi on six is one of them
five times six is the next one that's
the obtuse one and then i go
a full cycle of 2 pi right 12 pi and 6
to get to this one
i already know i'm already anticipating
that these ones will give me the initial
condition
these ones here will give me the oh it's
a full cycle later so that's why you end
up at four
this is the one in between that i'm
really interested in right
i i'd be probably pretty happy if uh
given everything else that you just did
in the question
you just went straight to this part
but i wanted to illustrate why i knew it
was going to be that one
which honestly under exam conditions i
don't instantly know i'm like i don't
know i'm just trying to solve stuff and
i haven't thought through
what each of the solutions will mean